témoignage cette fois ci d'un de nos
journalistes fabien rives testés
positifs au courant d'un virus il a
développé le virus lors d'un voyage en
slovénie à la frontière italienne
précisément il se trouve actuellement
dans un chalet réquisitionné pour
accueillir des patients étrangers
contaminés alors il ya un peu plus d'une
semaine j'étais en vacances avec un
groupe d'amis en slovénie et lors du
dernier jour du séjour au moment où mes
amis à venait de partir j'ai pensé
présenter des petits symptômes légers
pas très inquiétant mais d'ordre
respiratoire et quelques maux de tête
qui m'ont poussé à aller voir le docteur
et dans le contexte actuel en fait le
docteur ne reçoit pas les docteurs
slovènes ne recevait pas de patients
étrangers ce qui a fait que je suis allé
à l'hôpital où on a fini par me faire un
test du coronavirus et j'ai appris le
lendemain matin du test que j'étais
positif ce qui a fait que j'ai passé
près de cinq jours en confinement à
l'hôpital au terme de ces cinq jours ne
présentant pas de symptômes inquiétants
j'ai donc été transféré dans ce chalet
où je suis le premier arrivé et où je
devrais recevoir de la compagnie dans
les prochains jours peut-être d'autres
patients d'autres pays qui ne peuvent
pas rentrer chez eux et qu'ils seront
confinés ici le temps d'être testés
négatifs au virus